alain marie martias conseil de l'ordre
et quand ton fils y ait de la caraïbe
est notre guide pour la présentation de
ce temple attention voici le temple
maçonnique du grand orient de france à
la martinique
dès l'entrée nous sommes surpris par ce
mélange au sol de carreaux noir et blanc
si vous avez des cas au noir et blanc
c'est de ce conte retrouvant souvent en
informatique le 06 binaire comme dans
tous les lieux de culte cette salle est
équipée de fauteuils de table jusque là
rien de surprenant mais tels de
véritables symboles des pierres de
différentes formes sont placés aux
extrémités d'une estrade tout ce que
vous allez voir là ce sont des symboles
maçonniques sur lesquels nous
travaillons donc il faut quand même être
avoir une mine un minimum d'initiation
pour pouvoir comprendre la lune le
soleil un oeil dans un triangle font
partie de l'école des objets mystérieux
qui nous interpelle nous quand on
travaille on travaille pas uniquement
sur les symboles ce n'est qu'une partie
d'un au travail si vous voulez au grand
orient de france
nous avons une une proportion à traiter
des sujets de société
ils se retrouvent régulièrement ici dans
ces deux salles dans le cadre de
réunions
il déclare qu'il travaille sur
différents thèmes tels que le droit la
justice
le chômage le réchauffement climatique
autant de sujets utilisé par les
différentes institutions les politiques
souvent s'adresse à nos ou avant notre
avis sur le sujet parce qu'ils savent
que nous avons le temps de nous asseoir
et de réfléchir sur certains sujets dans
ce musée
il dispose aussi de pièces très rares
elle votera ce une bonne partie de
l'histoire maçonnique de lille le grand
orient de france est constitué de plus
de 400 membres en martinique
répartis en neuf loges en conclusion il
avance que la formation us ou même un
haut lieu symbolique à découvrir
elle regroupe en son sein des hommes et
les femmes de toutes les classes
sociales